chicago's mayor has apologized for the
very disturbing police raid that we
showed you yesterday the body cam video
we should warn you again is very tough
to watch
12 chicago police officers broke into an
innocent woman's home and handcuffed to
her
while she was naked the target of the
raid actually lived next door
and was even wearing a police ankle
monitor bracelet at the time
now city officials fought very hard in
court to keep you from seeing this video
investigative reporter dave savini of
our chicago station wbbm tv broke the
story
and has a mayor's response
young knowing that my words will not
change
what happened to you and your family
almost two
years ago i nonetheless say i
am sorry
in february 2019 12 armed male police
officers burst into the wrong apartment
and handcuffed and naked and jeanette
young
that was three months before chicago
mayor lori lightfoot took office
the mayor says she first saw the video
of the raid this week
the first i knew of this incident was
yesterday morning but it was lightfoot's
law department that tried to not only
stop
cbs chicago from showing the video but
also asked a federal judge
to punish young over the video's release
mayor lightfoot said she was not aware
of those efforts
if she had been she would have stopped
it we are not
nor would we ever seek sanctions
against miss young she
is a victim however the city has
requested a hearing scheduled for next
tuesday in federal court
seeking sanctions against young the
50-year-old social worker says the
mayor's public apology
has been her only communication and the
fact that she
has been no effort that i know of
to reach out to me or my team that's
more of a betrayal
young also has not been told if any of
the officers have been disciplined
and the city has not admitted any
wrongdoing but listen to this audio
captured
during the raid it wasn't initially
approved for some
crap what does that mean
i have no idea because i mean they told
him it was improved and then
i guess that person messed up on their
end
the chicago police department refused to
explain what you just heard
young says what she wants is
accountability so come back and tell me
how you're going to fix this so that
this never happens again to me or anyone
else
now the sergeant in charge of that raid
apologized to miss young
before he left but that rage should have
never happened like we said the suspect
was wearing an ankle bracelet he was in
the apartment right next door police
should have known exactly where he was
in fact
records show he may have even heard the
raid happening because he was home that
night
gail oh my goodness dave the more we
hear the story the more upsetting it is
first kudos to you bravo to you for
bringing this story to light
you know i'm curious you said that the
police sergeant apologized but when you
showed us a video yesterday
we see somebody going in and saying we
believe your story
that made me so angry because it implies
that it was a story she was telling
when the reality is she's telling a
truth it implies she's still a suspect
so when you say that they apologize did
they do anything else to help her that
night
what about the door that everybody broke
into
you and i talked about this they tried
to fix her door and what they they
couldn't fix it so they put it
they put an ironing board there to wedge
it shut imagine that that's what she had
holding her door shut
they promised someone would come out
from the city to fix it the next day but
nobody ever came
thank you thank you very much dave i'm
so glad that
angenette young didn't have to die for
this to become a national story that's
how big this story is getting and
it's getting really similar to brianna
exactly i actually called her yesterday
guys i called dave first to see if i
could talk to her to get her number so i
did call dave yesterday
and i wanted to talk to her because i
figured that this would trigger her this
story
you know she's been living this happened
two years ago yeah february 2019.
this happened two years ago and so she's
been living with it for two years and i
thought
it would trigger her with all of us
seeing that public humiliation and asked
her what is getting her through
she said her faith her very strong faith
her best friend you always need a best
friend
her best friend and she has a support
group and she says that she is a social
worker who specializes in trauma
yeah and now she's using her own skills
to help herself but it's very very very
not the only one who's been in a
situation like this and yeah anthony you
often bring up there are broader and
deeper questions now about what these
raids are based on yeah
the question is i mean you hear the guys
questioning in the police car
apparently maybe about the warrant the
question is where did that come from
i'm sure there were cops in that room
who were very angry at their fellow cops
who got them in that
situation on bad information exactly
right